- what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we are gonna be talking about
our thoughts on in cells hmm first of
all what's an in cell an in cell is
someone that's involuntarily celibate
hmm okay so they do not want to be
celibate but they are celibate okay so
they want to have sex but they're unable
to have sex okay now we'll be talking
about enforced monogamy as well here so
stay tuned for that second part of this
okay so why does someone want to have
sex but they can't have sex well
probably a multitude of reasons they're
not attractive
whether that be physically or
intellectually they might not have they
might be living in their mom's house
they might not even be financially
independent or wanting to have a big
vision for making some sort of impact in
the world so maybe they are just a
slobby person this can be a man or a
woman there are plenty of women that are
involuntarily celibate as well plenty of
women that are unable to have a man that
wants to have sex with them and the same
thing goes with men so this is a very
this is a new thing that came into my
life do you think Jordan Peterson was
the first one that kind of brought it
into perspective for me at least
but involuntary celibacy we just clean
up your room that's the answer to this
take on some responsibility to fix your
body if you're unhealthy fix it go and
work out and eat healthier if you're
intellectually unsatisfiable for people
you're not you're not satisfactory for
people intellectually then go and read
books go and watch intellectual videos
go learn things and go practice teaching
them to other people
until people see that hey this guy's
actually learning something or this
woman's learning something so become
intellectually sexy as well become sexy
for people if you're not going to work
on yourself clean up your own room to
become sexy
of course other women aren't going to be
attract to you other men aren't gonna be
attracted to you so another thing is you
have to take risks if you're across the
bar and you're never going to or at a
museum or at a social gathering of any
sort and you're not going to walk across
to go talk to the person that you find
attractive then that's you not taking
risks that's you further propagating
your involuntary celibacy you are
voluntarily being celibate because
you're not working on yourself you're
not taking risk and so this is the case
so you have to take the chance you have
to go walk across the bar the museum
social event wherever you're at and go
and say hey how's it going you know you
probably will get rejected that's the
thing we all fall on our face so much in
our lives but it's a growing and
learning experience a thousand times we
fall on her face and the thousand the
first time finally somebody says like
hey I'm attracted to you too let's go
back to my place and watch a movie or
whatever and then next thing you know
you're making out and then the good
stuffs going on so that's how you do it
you fall on your face a lot you go and
take these risks you learn how to ask
people really thought-provoking
questions you learn how to look at
people's eyes you learn how to be
emotionally intelligent and you learn
how to do things like touch someone else
really gently and politely and show
people that you care about them by
listening to them with your two ears one
mouth so all these different skills is
how to shatter through the ceiling of of
I'm gonna start calling a voluntary
celibacy because that is what it is is a
voluntary celibacy people are
voluntarily not working on themselves
whether they're men or women and they're
that's exactly what's going on with them
not being able to find somebody that
finds them sexually attractive so a
solution that was proposed was like this
enforced monogamy and what enforce the
monogamy means in this case is it means
that if a lot of people find a lot of
meaning and fulfilment in their lives
through mayor
or through a partnership and so if
you're going to if you're going to at
least get married or find a partnership
you're gonna find more meaning and more
fulfillment in your life than if you
didn't so as people are becoming
twenty-five thirty thirty-five forty and
are still a lot of a lot of Millennials
aren't that interested in getting
married when they're 25 anymore
a lot of Gen Z are definitely gonna be
waiting definitely gonna be waiting to
get married for a while and Gen
Millennials and Gen Z are expected to be
the first generation Gen Z especially
the first generation of people not only
to grow up on smartphones but also
potentially live forever there's a lot
of work that's going into that so their
lifespan can how that their health can
outpace the disease that's growing
inside of their body at late stages that
our healthcare advancements will outpace
the rate at which disease accumulates in
our bodies so because of that they're
gonna get married when they're 40 or 50
even potentially okay so then the
question is what are you gonna do until
40 or 50 and forced monogamy
okay so let's break this down further
okay enforcement agha me so at you know
if someone is involuntarily celibate or
voluntarily celibate and they're unable
to find a partner well why not say okay
let's put this person in the same room
as this person and see if they get along
and that they can have a good
conversation and become married so it's
now like you're trying to force people
to get married but it's more like
putting them in the same room and seeing
if they vibe together okay that might
not be a bad idea right it's like can we
make better social platforms like the
Tinder's and the bumbles and the okay
Cupid's and all the stuff that match
people based on similar interests yeah
of course we can do that stuff but
that's not like this enforcement oggi me
that's more like recommended
relationships
it's like recommending relationships
instead of enforcing monogamy that's
interesting so now we have voluntary
celibacy and recommended relationships
it's so funny okay so we recommend these
relationships maybe we put people that
you know have
had sex there there involuntarily
celibate put them in a room together and
see how they do so that would be an idea
of this you know recommending
relationships and that would be I think
a decent idea because people that are
unable to find people that have the same
interests as them they're not able to
risk walking across the bar because
they're too anxious maybe they can meet
somebody in a space like a tea shop or
whatever and that they can sit down and
have a conversation about each other and
get used to each other so that is a
quick bit about both in cells with our
thoughts on insults our thoughts on
enforcement nagas me we're gonna start
referencing it as voluntary celibacy
because you've got to work on yourself
you got to clean up your own room as do
i as does everybody constantly in a
process of cleaning up our own room and
becoming a better person and also
recommended relationships interesting
stuff everyone thanks for tuning it for
this episode of thoughts on much love